yoke up on me man shine should I get
ready are we going to the ground or
what's what's going on
how will you be found Oh Muslim guilty
or not guilty which is it I'll make it
real clear you bring civil law you go to
jail you break God's law you go to hail
you need to be a Christian because Jesus
is the Son of God it's a John 3:16 in
survival he's be with you welcome to the
D show I made a hole subscribe if you
have it already I'm gonna take it to
this clip real quick you're a bastard
what's right I haven't seen is you a
bastard child that's right you're a
bastard child your issue isn't with me
it's with my holy book
hey nice his religion is killing people
right now as you and I talking really
don't want good for you in we're just
Bible believers that's all now you can
see obviously this person these
extremists are trying to provoke the
Muslims and by standing in front of a
mosque we would say come in the mosque
come and sit down be a man be a decent
human being
and sit down and break bread with your
neighbor sit down and go ahead and ask
your questions but standing like some
vigilante like some thug in front that's
not the way to be mimicking the Prince
of Peace as you call them Jesus who we
love and that's what we're going to be
talking about here today on the Deen
show answering your questions that you
standing out in front of the mosque
might have or the misconceptions here in
the day show we'll be right back
the games for peace be with you Salaam
alaikum alaikum Salaam brother how are
you better hamdulillah good now you see
we're gonna go to this clip real quick
yep go ahead America yes this summer I'm
telling you I love you papa you love me
if you love me do me a favor when you
chop my head use a real sharp knife let
me show your love that way don't use a
dull blade show you love using a sharp
knife
oh honey of skin showing she's gonna
play your skin showing you need to cover
that face now we can see obviously they
have a maybe some miss-information they
have a big misunderstanding and they're
calling people to stand in front of the
mosque we're saying come in the mosque
true yes come break some bread with us
definitely yes what would you say to
someone like well sign and have a have
an American bread broken up between both
of us have some tea show off these
emotions in China
Brioni yes we're happy to share for free
recently there was a big you know you
have Islamophobia I don't know how it is
in Australia it's really good growing
here you have it seems like the KKK
you know they got rid of these silly
white robes the robes and now they end
up you know coming out in different
forms so this is that same in his
behavior but you had some individuals
who are standing in front of the mosque
they had a huge big rally they came in
the mosque and changed their ways they
got to sit and communicate with the
Muslims they totally changed their
perceptions people are seeing a picture
right now of one of the people who was
with the key organizers and totally
different perceptions show here's Jason
ledger and the organizer of Friday's
rally wearing the profanity-laced
t-shirts now things have changed out of
respect for the Islamic people knowing
what I know now since I have talked to
them and spoke with them no no I would
not do that again um just because I
don't want to offend or hurt those
people well at Friday's rally Leger
spoke with a group of people who pray at
the mosque and he was invited inside but
when I took a second to sit down and
listen to them
and actually enter their mosque and
going and watch some of their prayers it
was a beautiful thing and they answered
some of my questions that I had just in
Jesse 0.01 these Islamophobes first of
all the big mistake that they make is
they don't communicate with the Muslims
it's like I'm blaming somebody but I
haven't never spoken to them firsthand
and without this first-hand information
all that you have it's only
misconception either you want to believe
in it or you want to create a
misconception that's what you would be
with second point is I would say we
should feel sad for these people this is
a mental status this is some sort of
psychological problem that they have and
we have to you know be helpful to them
and support them in coming out of that
perception that they have now one thing
is I mean they've heard this many of
them but will repeat it again for many
people that don't because it really I
think it softens the heart and it's the
truth that there is no other religion
that makes an article to believe in love
Jesus is one of the Mighty's messages of
God but they say now they say no no you
don't love him because you don't accept
him as the only begotten Son of God well
I took John 3:16 it survived over not
only do you have a new son Casey point
number one as we discussed the son of
god the concept of son of god in the
bible the bible has a language it has a
language where it refers to anyone and
everyone as son of god it refers to
adamson of God David a son of God are
the prophets a son of God it says sons
and daughters of God it even says in
book of Romans chapter 8 verse 14 that
anyone who believes in God follows God
is a son of God it's a it's a metaphor
so everyone's a son of God based on that
so as but if you look at the original
Greek Hebrew word which the Jews used to
believe in they would translate the word
son of God and they would understand it
as servant of God
so as Muslims we do believe that Jesus
is son of servant of God and Jesus and
every other prophet is servant of God
including me you and everyone else so we
are all servants of God so truly from
the Christian perspective from the
biblical scripture is scriptural
perspective Muslims do believe in Jesus
the way he should be believed in that is
the servant of God did Jesus ever now
I'm now talking about some unambiguous
something unclear something clear that
he identified himself that I am God I'm
little son of God if you don't believe
that I came to die for your sins you're
going to the Hellfire did he ever say
that shot point number one never ever he
said that there is no unequivocal
statement in the entire Bible in any
version of the Bible that Jesus said I
am God already said I have come to die
for your sins
rather I'll give you a passage in Gospel
of Matthew chapter 5 verses 16 and 17 a
person comes to Jesus and he says how
gospel of matthew chapter 19 verses 16
and 17 gospel of matthew chapter 5 verse
16 and 17 in different places a person
comes to Jesus and he asks what good
thing shall I do to go to paradise isn't
it the right time for Jesus to say just
believe in that I've come to die for
your sins he says now for you to go to
paradise keep the commandment that's it
so you're going to keep the commandments
to go to paradise coming to the subject
of concept of God or Jesus claiming to
be divine point number 1 Jesus himself
denied from being divine he said in
Gospel of Mark chapter 12 verse 29 he
said Shema Israel ooh
Adonai Eloheinu Adonai ehad meaning here
o Israel the Lord our God is one Lord
it's like saying the precedent your
precedent and my precedent our precedent
is President Barack Obama now can Barack
Obama be you or me
no because the language I'm using I'm
saying our precedent is Barack Obama if
on the precedent my language would be I
am the president of yours but here I'm
saying our precedent is Barack Obama
Jesus is similarly saying in the Bible
the Lord our God is one Lord meaning
he's saying I can't be the Lord he goes
further in Gospel of John chapter 5
verse 30 amazing words of the Bible he
says I can of my own self do nothing as
I hear I judge and my judgment is just
because I seek not my will but the will
of the Father who sent me so if someone
saying I cannot do anything by myself
at least that person's not God exactly
yeah at least that person's not God
that's all so now he's continuously
denying from being God and that's clear
and it seems many people consider your
witness a Bible scholar a Christian
scholar of Christianity been studying
the Christian faith for a long time soon
of comparative religion so you
expert in this field you know the verses
people go check them out so there is not
any clear verse but there are clear
verses stating the opposite that's very
true there is not a single unequivocal
statement of Jesus peace be upon him in
the entire Bible in any version where he
said I am God imagine God comes on the
earth and forgets to say I'm God it just
does not add up so that's not the case
at all
but we worship the God of Jesus the one
that Jesus worth yes because you just
prayed in the Bible they didn't he fell
on his face like we do very true he was
when he was put on the cross according
to the Bible and Gospel of Matthew and
Luke he says he looks up any size li li
lama sabachthani my god my god why have
you forsaken me so he's praying to
someone according to the Bible he fall
on the face and he prayed to God so he
himself is praying to someone so let us
pray to the one whom Jesus prays so let
us follow Jesus is step by step in every
every move of his can you define now I
had actually a real situation where a
person had a real really hard time he
said look if God sent me on a mission
there's no way I'd be complaining to God
here we have Jesus allegedly complained
why have you per se forsaken me yes I
mean right there that's that's telling
you something right there
definitely that's right exactly now see
the Christians generally and the church
are taught that Jesus he willingly
sacrificed himself for the sins of the
human world and he gave himself to God
now these words of Jesus peace be upon
which are only inscribed in the Bible in
in the original language so if you go to
the Bible these are in its real terms so
Jesus says Li Li he's referring to God
and that's the name of the guard Li
which is very close to that oblique word
Allah so they were very similar he's not
calling God as God in English li li lama
sabachthani why have you for a second
why have you put me in this trouble so
he's actually praying to God he's
turning to God he's he's asking seeking
help from God that is what we should
pick up from that do we should turn to
God seek help from God and ask Allah
we're going to take a break and we're
going to help clarify for many of the
people given the benefit of doubt that
we misinformed they have some Mis
interpretations misunderstandings open
your heart we're going to be answering
some of these misconceptions you might
have with an expert in Christianity here
we come back on Adi show
where it can't have defects in it can it
if it is literally God's Word yes
it cannot have defects I mean this was
written by men you know that this is a
collection right even if you have
Matthew Mark Luke and John the Gospel
according to according to right the
thing about the Quran and the biggest
and you know I'll leave you with this is
the biggest thing for me is if the Quran
is exactly what it says it is and this
doesn't matter whether you're Muslim or
not if the Quran is what it says it is
the Quran is literally the Word of God
delivered via Gabriel to Muhammad who
was an unlettered man who couldn't read
or write right he was just told to
recite right that was the first thing
right first thing they still recited
right so if it is literally the Word of
God then that's pretty important to me
and before I became Muslim I said if
this is the Word of God then I'm going
to follow it because I'd be stupid not
to back here on the D show now Jesus
peace be upon him if you brought if he
just came back today yeah and you start
calling Jesus Jesus first he probably
wouldn't turn around because that wasn't
I mean he didn't I heard that name yes
and then if he was asked if you asked
them are you a Christian what would he
say he does not know the word
Christianity he does not know the word
Christian because Christ is actually a
latinized word name title of the
original name of Jesus which is Messiah
issue Messiah or ISA Messiah that is his
real name so he would not know what
Christian is or what Christianity is and
then if you look and you say how did he
call on God yes he invited people to one
God he continuously reiterated this
belief that there is only one God and he
used the same name that was used but in
the Bible in the Old Testament by Moses
and the previous prophets Shama Yisrael
Adonai Eloheinu Adonai had he uses the
same title I don't I Jesus uses the same
word in Gospel of Mark chapter 12 verse
29 I don't I the same God the one the
only one who has no image no face and
who is has no partners and he uses the
word on the cross NIE which is the same
title in Arabic Allah I see in this
Passion of the Christ if you see this
it's an aramaic yes they translate a la
ilaha yes
have you a bit annoyed because he
pronunciation in different languages
changes for example my name is Waseem in
arabic it means handsome I don't know
whether we agree with you John I'll
leave it there but I come to America
they said to me they call me Waseem you
go to Indian economy vas him but I
remain handsome doesn't matter how you
pronounce it so the name Allah in this
from languages they might pronounce it a
little different in in Hebrew alloy or
ello and in aramaic ilaha but it's all
the same name God the One God that's it
it's confusing enough when he's calling
out another name for God obviously you
know he's not God but some people say he
called on God by the name Jehovah ya
know the Bible has a language concern
here every word is there's something
called jaywalking you know it adds je to
it ye saw Jesus yahuwah Jehovah so that
Jay has been added up it does not exist
in its original form what my concern
would be from any language to another
language you don't change the pronoun
the proper noun the proper noun remains
the same Eddie you call you go to India
they'll call you Eddie they won't call
you JD right it does not change it
should not change the proper noun
remains the same the same with with
Jehovah the original name in the Bible
is yahuwah which resembles very similar
to the arabic name yeah how you yeah are
you yeah ah and means the same the
everliving God we accept that except
that we are with it we agree with it the
only thing is we said that remove the J
let the J leave live in its own place
mm-hmm and that will solve a lot of
issues okay so it's pretty clear now
some would open heart open mind is he
like hold on these this is seems like
Jesus if you look at it we mentioned
that he wouldn't say he was a Creed
never heard the word yes but if you ask
him did you submit to the will of God he
would say yes it's in the Lord's Prayer
not dive will be done not my will but
thy will that is actually in one word in
Arabic what is it yes exactly I'll just
quote that Gospel of John chapter 5
verse 30 he says I can of my own cell do
nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just because I seek not my
will but thy will and if you translate
that in Arabic it is an a Muslim own I
am Muslim I don't do things by my will
but the will of the Creator who sent me
is exactly saying the same thing in in
his language that's what is the
translation but if someone says no a
Christian is one who submits the will of
God no not but you can't
as they like yeah you can a Muslim is
literally right here submit story of God
Islam comes from the Arabic root word
Salaam Ansan peace and submission
submitting to the will of God and the
one who submits is more Islam that is
Muslim so the person who submits his
will to the will of God that's that's
what the title is I mean while this is
just clear as day I mean if you just
look up to the Sun you see it but if you
turn away from the Sun you got gonna see
you so I can help you're not looking for
the true if you're not going to see it
and it adds up tell us they say look you
know even the Mormons this is an
argument you hear a lot even the Mormons
believe in Jesus but they're not true
followers if you see in any religion
there are always these different sects
different schools of thought and within
the Christianity as well you got you
know Catholics Protestants and within
them and then you got more moments and
now you have the Jehovah's Witness all
of these are different believes in God
and have different perspectives some
believe Jesus is God some believe Jesus
is in Trinity some believe Jesus is not
God so all of these are different sects
what do you do you come back to the
scripture what Jesus taught us in the
gospel and from that we can all come
back towards the original thing original
teaching of Jesus peace be upon him and
Jesus very clearly said in various
places of the Bible that you know
worship one God and that's it we go with
that go back to basic worship a creator
not to create another argument that many
of them will have is saying that look
Jesus was sinless Muhammad he sinned
yeah and the Quran was revealed to a
person to sin Jesus he didn't sin so
therefore he must be God yet okay no
it's a very good theory to believe Jesus
is sinless as Muslim we believe Jesus is
sinless so are all the other prophets
but let's come to the Bible what does
Bible say no Bible has passages where it
says Jesus had a woman who came to him
and seek help and he said to her it is
not for me to give the bread to the dogs
imagine if I call someone a dog in this
society today is that not considered a
sin it is according to the language of
the Bible Jesus committed sin he
converted water to wine if I give wine
to under-18s in America today I can
assure you I will be in trouble right so
Jesus is giving that according to the
law it would be a crime Jesus says in
Gospel of Luke chapter 19 verse 27 he
says anyone who does not accept my reign
to rule over them
them and slay them in front of me this
is according to the Bible according to
the Bible read letters read letters in
the Bible is direct words of Jesus peace
be upon him and he says in Luke 19:27
whoever does not believe in me bring him
here
slay them this is sin so according to
the Bible Jesus is sinful according to
Islam Jesus is sinless so yes we believe
is sinless now someone who says no no
but Muhammad is sinful in that
perspective even Jesus is sinful
according to the Bible now what we say
is whatever the prophets did it is
according to the command of God so that
is no sin now they have to pick up a
particular matter where they said this
is sin so they say Muhammad killed
people no Moses also killed people but
that was the command of God to fight
against those who fight you
so if Eve comes to your house and
smashes your wife and your children and
you hit him back
you are they say oh no no you are a
criminal you hit someone yeah but I hit
in a context in a reason I'm not going
out killing people or attacking
someone's house but someone attacked my
house I have to defend so if someone
attack Mohammed's house if someone
attacked his country and killing
innocent people as of leader you got a
defend you gotta fight back that's what
it did if Jesus was the king of his time
I can assure you he would have fought
back and he would have killed a few who
were killing innocents yeah three
thousand actually mentioned Moses three
thousand and one day according to the
Bible now according to the Bible the
Christians believe Jesus is God so Moses
killed people under whose command and
the gods command who is God according to
some Christians Jesus
so who commanded Moses to kill Jesus so
it was a God's command so is the same
command from Muhammad peace be upon him
to fight and kill for the innocence for
the truth to save the lives in a just
war in a just war exactly so we're going
to take a break here on a Deen show
we'll be right back with more don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the D show
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show let's go ahead
we're going to go right back to the clip
and really creating a you know outside
of a house of worship creating this just
comfortable atmosphere people coming out
from worshipping God to this surprise
men you don't even have a chance to
think they're in a dream or something
you got these people with you know
insulting their religion let's go to
this clip real quick and then you will
bow before a true King king of King and
Lord of lords Jesus Christ the only
begotten Son of God but you will stand
before and give it a cow okay coming
back so people can see now one thing as
we open up come inside the Masjid this
is our first visit to a mosque it was
absolutely fascinating we had the
opportunity to do a tour and learned a
lot about Islam and what the mosque is
about what the faith is about what the
culture is about and there are many
misconceptions that were cleared up for
us yes it was a very enriching religious
and cultural experience I felt very at
home very comfortable and it was it's
such a peaceful environment and it does
reflect on the people in the religion
and the culture it was a fascinating
experience and I I am encouraged to
learn more about it come and sit and
talk with your brother humanity we might
not agree on some things but we can have
a healthy dialogue to make the
communities the world that we live in a
better place the guy's obviously promote
provoking he's mentioning one thing look
he's he saying that okay look look I'm
an infidel what you're supposed to do
with me actually got a shirt yeah it has
a line across it saying cut here buddy
is a to see whatever one some some of
these people have no understanding and
no clue of the religion that trying to
represent support of a one they try to
pick up some misconceptions they've been
you know bombarded with with wrong
understanding and misinterpretation of
Islam and they buy it and and then they
try to provoke with that point number
one we tell them see what you're trying
to propagate is is part of your religion
as well you're trying to only pick up
one aspect and lead the other they say
Islam says to kill and behead right
allah subhanaw taala says in any i of
the quran when he says to fight if you
read the same words complete it says to
fight those who fight against you so
it's only a reaction it's only to
protect not to kill people by default
and if that was true what he's claiming
he would have been attacked by now right
yeah but he's not rather he is the one
attacking he's going all the way to the
mosque with 1,000 worshippers all day
but he's not yet attacked right
yeah so what he's claiming is backfiring
him he's not right according to that
coming back to the Muslim community what
should a Muslim do in that situation
Allah says in the Quran in surah 2 ayah
surah number 103 number 3 what I saw
this summer at that time be patient
that's what exactly you got to do so you
be patient in that case and just
communicate and can wait at the time
that's the best that you should do now
here's an he'll say look that the the
Bible condemns all false gods false
religions what do you say see many
people again cannot relate Islam with
all of these religious dating Islam is a
new religion it's a different religion
they fail to realize Islam is the most
inclusive religion Islam includes
everyone what is Judaism to believe in
Moses and to follow the Torah as a
Muslim I am commanded to believe in
Moses and follow Torah technically every
Muslim is already a Jew Christianity to
believe in Jesus and follow gospel every
Muslim is technically already a
Christian it believes in Jesus and
follows the gospel Buddhism says to
believe in karma what you do comes back
to you aslam already believes in in a
very organized format of karma whatever
you do you will have it back on the day
of judgment so it's a complete system it
includes every faith and belief now what
these people are trying to do is they're
separating Islam with everything else
for example they think Islam has no
alcoholism right if you come back to
that even the Bible says the same allah
says in the quran in surah - 4 number 5
on number 3 so above a certain number to
a number 173 that alcohol is been
prohibited the prophet salaallah said
I'm said in soon an even major one in
number 3 Hadees number 3371 that alcohol
is the mother of all evils so it should
be stopped but people think Nana this is
just Islamic thing nothing to do with
the other religions but the Bible says
in book of proverbs chapter 20 verse 1
book of Ephesians chapter 5 verse 18 it
says that even alcohol is prohibited it
says even the pork that what Islam says
pork is prohibited this is also
prohibited in the Christian Bible it
says you know in in Book of Leviticus
chapter number 11 verses 7 and 8 book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 14
was number 8 Polk is prohibited so all
of these Islam is only a continuation of
the teachings of Christ how Christianity
is the continuation of the teachings of
Moses Islam is the continuation of the
teachings of Christ and the fulfillment
of that now we covered earlier clearly
there are no clear statements that Jesus
ever said he was God to worship Him a
literal son of guy he was a servant of
God all the evidence points that he was
a mighty Messenger of God just like
Abraham Moses Noah they all call people
to worship the Creator not the creation
now in the flip side what is clear in
the Bible and also in the Quran that if
someone sets up a partner next to God is
that if someone worships some what
worship a messenger is saying tonight Oh
an icon you know dead person or ground
that can end you up in the Hellfire
forever
exactly now this this is exactly the
teaching of the Bible it's as well it
clearly states the committing of shirk
associating a partner to God book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 6 verse
number 4 book of Deuteronomy chapter 20
verses 3 to 5 a book of Exodus chapter
number 20 verses 3 to 5 all of these
verses very clearly claim that anyone
who associates a partner with God God
says I am a jealous God and I will
punish you for that
so God is absolutely clear in the Bible
that you should not associate a partner
with that a lot of analysis is similar
in the Quran in surah - remember 5 our
number 72 Allah subhana Allah says in
whom I usually billa [ __ ] her AMA
allez allez heal Jenna
wahoo not that anyone who commits
association with God commits shirk there
is for paradise has been forbidden and
they will be thrown in the Hellfire so
should that is associating partners with
God worshiping another god a false god
or a fake God according to every
religion Judaism Christianity and Islam
this is not permissible so we always
stand united on monotheism of God
so the moment someone makes the Statue
and worships it you're breaking your own
religion straight away wow this is a
really point clear I mean and we
obviously when you take it back and you
look at how Jesus lived his life how he
call people to have a relationship with
the Creator it called people away from
idol worship worshipping himself he
didn't even want to be called good right
exactly let alone God it seemed like
Abraham Moses and the last if I don't
your problem Hamid peace be upon them
and other shows we've we've also we're
almost short on time they go ahead and
slur insults yet the Prophet Mohammed
Khan book war Muslims your guys are
lukewarm here's an infidel right here
yeah you got that little girl she's
married material right now your prophet
when she Muslims get emotional how do
you respond now this is a time where we
live now when when the when the people
who hate something they can't find a
rational reason they pick up into this
bigotry they pick up into this hate and
they pick up into this abuse so this
point number one it shows a straight
away that they don't have rational at
rationality anymore now how do we
respond to that first of all I would
like to let these Islamophobic bigots
know that the very religion you are
abusing this religion does not even
allow us to abuse you back we believe in
such a mighty religion you make cartoons
of Prophet Mohammed Prophet Muhammed
said in Sahil Bihari volume number nine
Hadees number 646 he said you cannot
make cartoons so if you make hundred
cartoons of Prophet Mohammed I to
respond to you I can't make a cat one
cartoon of yours because Muhammad peace
be upon him said to me don't abuse
anybody with making cartoons so I will
never respond to you abusing point
number two the French cartoonist who
made the cartoons the French people they
have to realize this the same cartoonist
and the same magazine was banned by the
French government a few years ago for
making a abusive cartoon of an
ex-president of France come on you
banned him already but when he makes
cartoons of Prophet Mohammed he said nah
nah he's allowed to make so this is
complete hypocrisy on a institutional
level but what do we do how do we
respond to them education this is very
important how do I respond to these
biggest especially in the France who
abuse the Prophet sallallaahu mind the
mother French history Lamartine a very
prominent French historian writes in his
book historic dinner took published from
Paris in the year 1854 volume number 2
page number 276 he says if greatness of
purpose smallness of means and
astounding results are the three
criteria to judge any human genius who
could dare compare any great man in
modern history with Muhammad peace be
upon him if the French history is
evident of the greatness of Prophet
Muhammad then the French should abstain
themselves from abusing such a great man
amazing thank you so much we're out of
time if people want to get a hold of you
they want to invite you to some of their
campuses maybe where this incident took
place yet would these people be invited
also definitely I would love to
communicate with them see this is what
you've got to do for the Prophet
Muhammad do with Abu jahil communicate
can why and what did he do from amongst
them warmer became Muslim it is always
possible one last example I'll give you
know there's a big politician from
Netherlands get will ders he his job is
to spread a right-wing extremism against
Islam and prophet muhammad sallallahu
salam one of his research men are not
when doon who used to research against
prophet mohammed for years two years ago
through his research on the biography of
prophet mohammed where his full-time job
is to take out mistakes he said I could
not resist becoming a follower of
Prophet Muhammad 2013 he goes to Makkah
he embraces Islam he goes to the city of
Medina he was part of the fitna movie as
well the abusing movie made against
Prophet Mohammed he rendered and he said
I have spent my time abusing the Prophet
I'll spend the rest of my life I promise
to bring back the praise to Prophet
Muhammad amazed you can't resist
following this man thank you so much may
God Almighty Allah 100 inaudible on I
mean and we covered a lot in this
episode one don't stand outside the
mosque come inside the mosque be man
enough courageous enough to sit it's
easy just to let out hot venom sit back
let's have some tea some choice some
coffee and talk to the Muslims you got
to learn a lot from this episode you
might not agree but the facts made it
clear from a Bible expert a Christian
expert here on Christianity that nowhere
did ever DZ's ever call people to
worship himself as a god or a literal
son of guy he was a servant of God he
fell on his face and he prayed to God he
called people to worship the Creator not
the creation and you see what Islam
talks about as far as violent so you got
your facts your information all mixed up
so I'm glad you tuned in to the D show
to find out the truth and God willin
when you pray to God directly because
you might be confused a lot of the
things you've heard it's not adding up
and you came here like wow this stuff
makes sense the first point of reference
is to do what Jesus did call on God
Almighty alone and ask him to make it
clear
and the truce cell shut you free
otherwise you're going to be living with
this hatred and anxiety in your heart
and you're just going to be upset in
yourself and other people and at the end
what do you got nothing subscribe to the
Dean show if you haven't already
continue to tune in here every week and
until next time we'll see you that peace
be with you please subscribe to the D
show follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]